[Music]
yeah that's how it all started for me is
I was in a band and the van broke up
like college bands do because everybody
had to get jobs and I was teaching
waterskiing at this camp and they said
there's gonna be a religious service and
who wants to give the sermon and I said
I will and then all of a sudden you know
you say something and the words come out
of your mouth and then you're like wait
what give a sermon I had heard a few
sermons growing up and I always thought
that the sermon raised that existential
question what's for lunch you know it
was just boring but I came out of band
world where you engaged an audience
where there was something happening in
the room from the back row to the front
let's all go somewhere together and so I
remember doing my first sermon and
thinking this is why I'm here I'm gonna
reclaim the sermon as this lost art form
for many people in our culture the
sermon is just a belief affirmation
device just tell people what they
already think so you all can feel smug
and your rightness further people the
sermon is how you convince people to
give money so you can build bigger
buildings for some people the sermon is
just how you get people to vote a
certain way but you think about Martin
Luther King I have a dream now that's a
sermon nobody heard that sermon and the
thought I don't know he's usually
funnier you know what I mean you were
either there or you won't it was
dangerous and comforting and healing and
provocative and you learned something
and it gave you a new vision for what
might be possible that the sermon is an
art form and in many ways in our culture
it's been lost and some of us are trying
to reclaim it as this art form that
somewhere between performance art and
guerrilla theater and a TED talk and a
recovery meeting and a revival and that
a sermons for everyone the sermon isn't
for a particular people who have already
agreed that they all believe a
particular narrow set of things a sermon
is about what it means to be human and
so a sermon is poetry a sermon is
science a sermon is visual a sermon is
experiential I've set stuff on fire I've
had actors planted in the odd
I've built solar systems out of exercise
balls that we hung from the roof I've
used live animals I've done the sermon
backwards and then forwards to make a
larger point about time everything you
can think of I probably tried in in
relation to a sermon and like right now
I do a local I do a residency at a club
in West Hollywood near Riley of a comedy
club called Largo and I do these like
hour and 15-minute hour and 30 minutes
service I guess you call it a sermon
one-man show and I want to take you
somewhere and its history and it's
anthropology and its theology and
sometimes it's funny and it's pop
culture and it's data about all kinds of
things and it all Masha's together but
we want to be inspired we want new
insight into who we are and who we are
we as human beings meaning is like
oxygen for the Soul we want to know what
it means we want to know where it's
headed we want to make sense of our past
we want to know how to forgive we're
looking to make connections because
otherwise the world is fragmented and
fractured it just comes at you with no
narrative thread and one of the things
that sermon does is it connects to this
to this to this and you walk out of
there with a little more sense of
centered grounding like oh yeah that is
who we are
that is who I am that is what we're
doing here and that's that's to me a
sermon yeah I always begin with the
depth of the common so you are going
about your life and you're getting
coffee in the kitchen at work and
somebody says man I had a rough weekend
you can oh my word
Joan is so annoying thank you Oh bill
neither one of his weekend stories you
can sort of or that can be a door and
you can open it and you can say tell me
why your weekend was so rough
because the person when they say my
weekend was so rough they're basically
saying could you please ask me about my
weekend and you have no idea they may be
splitting from their partner their kid
may be sick they may be in serious
financial trouble they may have a
relative who just got a cancer diagnosis
so I begin with there's more going on
here and there's always depth in the
common everyday mundane average moments
of life but you have to be moving a
half-step slower so I begin with most of
us are missing all of these fascinating
stories all of these insights and it's
like the whole universe is a megaphone
and it's speaking to us it's reminding
us what matters but generally we have
our head down and we're checking our
texts and then I begin secondly that
there is the universal and there is the
particular so there are the particulars
of a story what she was wearing he was
driving a Ford she was in the front seat
and a green sweater it was a Thursday it
was raining you saw them in a parking
lot you saw them arguing you realized it
was some ugly fight between these two
lovers and they happen to be having it
in the parking lot of the drugstore and
you described the details in the
particulars of that moment the universal
is love can break your heart and it
takes a while it takes a lot of work to
keep a relationship together so there's
the particular and then there's a
universal which is true for all of us
and so a sermon is moving back and forth
between the particular x' and the
universals and it knows the power of a
good story and it knows how that story
is true at some level for all of us and
then thirdly a sermon is about good news
what good news do you have to bring us
oftentimes the good news needs bad news
for it to be good news so we're doing
some horrible things to our environment
we're polluting rivers or filling
landfills we've got issues with the
ozone layer we've got
climate change that's the bad news the
good news is we can do something about
it we can all like take little steps in
our day-to-day lives to actually change
the way we think about the soil and our
relationship to the environment so a
sermon if it doesn't have good news at
some level then it's missing sort of the
key thing but for it to be real solid
actual authentic good news it's gonna
have to be honest about just what a mess
we've made of this place
[Music]